the Joe Rogan experience I got a couple
different color suits nice like three or
four different ones in black shirt
anymore well I have black shirts but now
I have like real close real black pencil
black like an adult I never wear black
shirts because so much [ __ ] every time I
totally I throw away
I had black shirts to go with everything
I [ __ ] throw them with people at home
by the way any Bravo outside as I pulled
up thought I was Joe Dirt walked up to
me like hey oh hey Jimmy and I was like
he [ __ ] thought I was just and he
goes thought you were Joe dude and I was
like you came in with an old Bhaskar so
yeah I don't work [ __ ] black shirt
I'm so sorry you're before me I was
[ __ ] freaked out but it's cool that's
alright no no it's just an illustration
of the natural my mom got us confused
one time I'm not even [ __ ] joke oh no
I don't your mom's house she was making
she's an amazing cook she's Greek you
guys have to come over again have dinner
sometime so we came I went to her house
she's making me dinner and we're
watching the UFC she turns around she
goes oh this is one of yours no mom
that's Joe Rogan and she goes she
[ __ ] pause she goes man he looks like
you a day on the Internet
I'm gonna get this from my own mother
but I still ate the food you you got
that but one of the things about you do
you don't toot your own horn it's like
your general like universally respected
thank you with people that know the
sport you know which is why I was
campaigning to get you hired whether you
have two years ago I'm like this guy's
the [ __ ] hasn't stopped if I swear I'm
excited man and I'm excited too for Big
John
I love John and I'm excited he got that
gig I hope that really works out well
for him and I think it's gonna be
interesting I understand completely
kind of the step and then I don't recall
a referee ever doing calm
I mean he did affliction he did the
first affliction show but it's a
different perspective he's seeing it
from an angle that no fighter or coach
is really gonna see yeah and so I think
it's great cuz any you know any fighter
is gonna be compared to all the other
fighters into it a referee he's just
gonna have a different perspective and I
think that's a good choice if he does it
with John or if John does it with Mike
Goldberg and John are real good friends
first show is Michael that's belief I
believe all don't quote they're real
good friends so that should just be real
easy yeah Mike's easy to work with
he's Mike's easy to work with Mauro was
too both guys were easy to work with
they're very different but both guys
were easy to work with man I was I was
impressed with both of them yeah Mike's
Mike's a sweetheart look we need more
work for a lot of guys but yeah what for
what we do there's not a lot of guys
that do it you know this Paul Felder who
I think does a [ __ ] phenomenal job
and I would have loved to listen to him
tonight if we weren't yapping but he
does a great job he's a smooth smooth
guy very smooth I think Dan Hardy does a
great job you know Brian Stann was one
of my favorites I was bummed out and
Brian left yeah he prepared better than
anybody Brian Stann will pull out [ __ ]
about training and all these different
weird things you didn't know about
preparation and other things that
fighters dude that this guy did that was
unusual and like his preparation was top
of the food chain it's a full-time job
don't get that you know in terms of like
um you know when I'm not doing
commentary I'm studying fights all the
time because I'm not just watching them
I gotta sit there and study them which
is a totally different job what's funny
is Joe never done for [ __ ] myself Joe
would just walk on and just crash with
no preparation maybe a couple of
thoughts couple notes but he wasn't
preparing at all it was hilarious like
it's too easy all the things I do live
do you think about how much stand-up I
do live yeah then how much podcast I do
live like this before the podcast true
that is true
yeah well you know the thing was look
they they wanted to have like some sort
of planned out interaction between like
that's one of things that people would
freak out about like when we would do
the beginning of the fight and goldware
bolt Goldberg would say like Matt Hughes
fights Frank Trigg for the UFC
welterweight title you know and this is
an important fight he wouldn't know what
the [ __ ] I was gonna say I don't know
what he was gonna say I didn't know what
I was gonna say I had no idea but I knew
about the fight yeah my point was like
it's better to be in the moment and
really care about this fight and care
about what I think is gonna happen and
not have anything planned out I just
wanted to be able to go this is what's
critical in this fight and we're gonna
know early on whether or not you know
the fights gonna go one way or other
based on a couple of parameters and I
would just go into those things and and
then after it'd be over I worked out
yeah but easy for you man no I don't
need the Godfather a hundred percent but
but but what I what I tell people don't
write down you'll think about what did I
write down rather than the I tell people
I go never play-by-play to you of course
but I go color don't write down notes or
don't write down here's what I'm gonna
say because start thinking about what
you wrote down you fake and you'll sound
fake it doesn't work
[Applause]